and burgundy numbers as we're underway and Travis
durot goes back to get in his own Zone but can't
clear it's Terry who gets a chance and that
one ricocheted off the goal post came right
back to him then watch the pass to Troy Terry
cuz he's going to just love this read Cassian
carries it in and hands it off at the strike Terry
immediately enged but he gets it back walks to the
slot shoots big save Ingram cassan was blocking
out the sun in front take away the eyes of the
goenda breakout here into the
middle Shawn dery reaching at it
knocked Away by zigris but he took it
back and here's a chance off the goal
post boy they are glad to have him back on the ice
and get getting them ready for the regular season
right in front Gibson makes a nice save as Gunther
circled around and found himself at the far post
melli and we get set to begin the second period
of play so it's back to Carlson with ZR and Terry
to begin the period and the veteran Travis Boyd
deposing Carlson who wins the draw won't be 19
years of age until the day after Christmas or
as you Canadians call it boxing in day Keller's
shot goes off of Gibson and out of play coming off
the line didn't get a lot on his backhander though
Lassie Thompson hangs on to it as Jason zooker
nearly took it away did not it loose and Logan
coie scores well that's a bad turnover for Lassie
Thompson and and like all young defenseman you've
got to learn when to make the safe play when
to recognize that the pressure is significant
enough to put you in Jeopardy and me the coyotes
get in on the for check a little pressure on him
he couldn't handle a little mishandle right
there and then he coughs it up John Gibson
let's see what happens with Gibson got the stick
knocked out of his hands and he's spin it around
to pick up Leon comes back recovers possession
angles it off the boards for Carlson just overl
him and a good play by Ingram who came out to
swat it away just trying to throw it off the
wall was Leon and let Carlson skate into it
and out to the front of the net again kerfoot
scores oh Alexander kerfoot one of those
players that signed with the coyotes and
he's going to get a lot of ice time but I tell
you what kerford has got some upside offensively
there's the turnover Thompson kind of caught
that one up too it's been a rough initiation
for Lassie Thompson and the turnover proves
costly nothing that John Gibson can do about
that shot and Keller handles on the rightwing
half wall curls it back to the line Shawn dery
the former Los Angeles King is there Keller
moves it right on the doorstep Hatton tried
to draw it in front but he drew attention as
leushin took it away and now battles the puck
off the end boards dery able to keep Carlson pops
out high zis in front looking for a redirect from
McTavish came clean through to Terry who fires
wide boy good screen from McTavish I Ingram
saw it Terry just missed his shot he tries again
nice pass across seis and a sprawling save doing
the splits by Ingram looking for a change and
Carrick will just hoist it in and head to the
bench for that said change Gunther meantime
takes a stretch pass ahead puts it into space
for kolie and melli hit the goal post I'm not
sure that one entered the trapezoid but they
say play on the officials think so that's
all that matters schaltz muscles his way in
over to Keller he hit the goal post Clayton K is
just so deceptive when he gets that puck on his
stick he has tremendous Vision on the ice
and we we've seen flashes of that certainly
in this game tonight underway to begin the third
Troy steter tried to go up the Middle with that
pucky hit loss in Krauss with it and enables the
Ducks to regain possession now he carries in and
hands it off Henrik puts a puck out in front of
him to keep it away from Barrett Hatton back to
the line line Fowler quickly across McTavish
dusts it off he hit the goal post what is it
about that end of the ice the right hand of
[__] boy the Ducks hit a couple of pipes on
that power play across room time for silverberg
back to mnov his pass a little off the mark so
he gets it right back Carlson right back to zis
they move it around Carlson in front silverberg
with a quick shot off of Ingram straight up in
the air went behind the Ed Zas found at first
Carlson to mnov wrist shot didn't get through
and carm's Out Center Ice Logan [__] gets to
it first in short-handed and a last minute poke
check knocks it away penalty coming up to the
Ducks and a penalty shot coming up for Logan
kie slow at first left shot swings in off the
right side scores off the post and [Music]
in because it gives them such an advantage
when they're when they SL blow it right down
they can move the puck around try and get a
golender to bite on something that's just a
beautiful shot by Logan [__] John Gibson I
guarantee you thought he had that angle on the
blocker side completely covered over to zooker
who hangs on to it and his pass kept at the left
Point by valami now melli across and that handcuff
zooker melli again for zooker right back to
machell score Bo what a nice pass that was Cris
passing of the net but here's the first pass from
melli and boy when this return pass is allowed to
get through it really puts Gibson in a tough
spot you can see that Gibson's trying to get
over to protect that short side but so a little
later getting to the NHL perhaps got a few games
before last two seasons ago and then last season
the whole year here's Carlson he speeds in and
goes backand and good got that gas kind of banks
It Off the Wall to himself and gets it out of
Harm's Way nice play there by Radco here's Carlson
he's in can't sneak at five hole on Ingram Troy
Terry at the side of the net and the Arizona net
Miner will cover it's a smart little play When the
goenda for their Defenders you know makes
the breakout so much easier Mavish skates
into one off the wall he hit the the goal post
two onone with stro he took the shot he wins
the puck Coyote's changing Ducks try to find room
in the neutrals on Terry nice little pass Carlson
busts in again tried to chip it over and I think
Ingram got a piece of it then they have back Tob
backs the following weekend that include the
Boston Bruins a team who had a record setting
year a season ago as Lon speeds the other way
and sets up the first go the hockey game car
buries it off just a beautiful Rush up the ice
by Brett Leon and tell you what where' he go
to score goals in this league go to the top of
the goal crease nice little dump feed by Leon
just throws it to the top of the crease may
have got a yell at that point from Sam and a
nice little finish as he out raced Liam O'Brien
Ducks able to win a puck battle off the draw and
spinning with it is Troy Terry wants to bring
it to the front and it went right through his
intended target Fowler with a keep and a hard
one timer from McTavish ricochets off the end
boards he gets it back across silverberg had to
dust it off loose in front and cassum Taps it
[Music] in the Ducks were able to get kind of
those 50/50 puns back on their stick that's
the first really mistake I would say by Ingram
made in this game because it was a shot to the
glove side and it appeared to go off the heel
of the catching glove and it's a TA in for Zack
Cassie the ice excuse me the ice time for
Trevor zis over 24 minutes as the final 5
Seconds come to an end stock had returned to
the crease and this one is in the books the
final home preseason game for the Ducks is
a 4-2 defeat at the hands of the coyotes is